un peu rude bellemare vous croyez pas
dans des moments comme ça même si vous
avez permis cette rencontre la caméra
aides publiques sont un peu trop
mangeons crois pas je crois qu'il bien
sûr tout ce qui se passe à la télévision
est forcément spectacle les pires choses
son spectacle la télévision et puis les
plus belles aussi toutes les enquêtes
nous menons nous les menons à la demande
des personnes et je crois que le
meilleur compliment qu'on nous ait fait
c'est justement à la fin de cette
émission là où monsieur certains qui
étaient venus plein de prévention nous a
dit je pensais que vous faisiez
uniquement un spectacle pour les autres
je me suis aperçu vous faisiez aussi une
émission pour nous
je pense que c'est cet équilibre là qui
est essentiel nous ne pouvons réussir
cette émission elle ne peut avoir de
sens que si on la fait aussi et surtout
pour ceux qui sont là sur le plateau
maintenant évidemment c'est aussi un
spectacle pour le téléspectateur mais je
ne pense pas qu'il soit gênant de voir
quelque chose lorsqu'il s'agit de
quelque chose qui est fait avec une
certaine pudeur et surtout quelque chose
qui est heureux nous ne nous permettrons
pas de faire quelque chose de scandaleux
ou deux malheureux nous interdisons et
je peux vous dire que dans cette
émission pour un cas que nous passons
sur l'antenne il y en a vingt que nous
ne pouvons pas baser sur l'antenne et
que donc on referme dont nous refermer
les dossiers purement et simplement ne
fait pas parfois naître un faux espoirs
nous essayons qu'il n'y en ait pas je ne
suis pas sûr que de ce côté là nous ne
soyons pas de temps en temps qu'on parle
car c'est vrai je le reconnais mais nous
essayons par tous les moyens que ça ça
n'existe pas mais ce n'est pas facile
c'est c'est très délicat fait des
missions difficiles à faire et tellement
passionnante que j'y consacre vraiment
mais je rêvais nuit avec un très très
grand plaisir
[Musique]